[Musique]
oh
catherine il y à un élément très
important de rêverie et de devis secret
quel que soit le rôle qu'on lui donne on
a l'impression qu'il y a le rôle qui est
sur l'écran et qu'il ya d'autres pensées
qui ne sont pas exprimés et on le pense
toujours ça et on ne pensera pas d'une
autre actrice qui aura l'air de dire
tout ce que tout ce qu'elle pense tout
ce qui lui passe par la tête
[Musique]
comme catherine est une fille très
pudique à la une chance d'être un mythe
comme elle est mystérieuse et comme elle
n'a pas envie de tout dire elle a une
chance d'être un mythe prime de mes
joies justement ça a été de faire
rejoint la team de comédie à catherine
deneuve pour la première fois dans la
vie de château il a été absolument
extraordinaire dans la vie de château
est extraordinaire dans le sauvage de
force de dynamisme de drôlerie avec ce
sérieux qu'elle a dans ces situations là
[Musique]
des racines quand même que quelques en
avants comme comme elles puissent a
accepté un rôle sans connaître les
scénarios
normalement ça ne se fait pas je pense
que catherine quelqu'un avec qui on peut
aller très loin dans le justement c'est
là où toutes les prises de risques très
loin dans le désarroi très loin dans la
dérive très loin dans quelque chose qui
ce quelqu'un qui qui s'abandonne et qui
est un qui n'est plus qui est absente à
elle-même parce qu'elle garde dans cette
circonstance fait une sorte de grandeur
qui est la sienne et qui fait que le
personnage n'est jamais complaisant par
rapport à elle même elle donc émouvante
ans à quoi
[Musique]
j'ai pensé tout de suite à catherine
deneuve parce qu'elle représente la
femme française
et puis je me suis dit aussi que c'était
un défi de lui proposer un rôle de
potiche parce qu'elle n'est pas du tout
aux tiges dans la vie et que ça pouvait
être amusant
[Musique]